when i got to lecture them i said i'm
going to give you the lecture i wish
somebody had given me 50 years ago when
i was a first year med student i would
have changed every diagnosis i made
would have changed every treatment plan
i made it's the food your patients are
eating before you order another thousand
dollar scan another five hundred dollars
said a lab test stop
ask what they ate yesterday to have to
take you through an eating day and if
it's full of burgers and buffalo wings
and pepperoni peaches that's why they're
sitting in front of you doctor
overweight diabetic hypertensive clogged
up and inflamed from what they're
running through their bloodstream every
four hours
that was dr clapper one of my favorite
plant-based doctors who has inspired me
for more than a decade dr clapper is a
general practitioner with a zest for
life full of youthful enthusiasm and is
a picture of health at 74 years old he
is a well-recognized teacher around the
world that shares evidence-based
nutrition and has decades of experience
reversing patients chronic illness and
disease with lifestyle medicine
integrative medicine and plant-based
nutrition he has done so much work
helping eradicate chronic lifestyle
illnesses and now he lectures at medical
schools across the country to empower
the next generation of doctors to better
heal their patients with plant
predominant nutrition and lifestyle
changes to get to the root cause rather
than treating the symptoms all with the
moving medicine forward initiative you
can find them at drclapper.com and it
would be so great if you subscribe to
his youtube channel dr clapper filled
with vital information at your
fingertips i'm very proud to share his
wealth of information with you all
welcome to the yellen fisher podcast
let's get started all right we are on
thank you so much dr clapper for coming
on the show today my whole family has
been looking forward to you and your
wife's visit and we are thoroughly
enjoying our time here
you are just such a joy to be around and
same with your wife elise as well so
thank you so much for coming here oh
well thank you ellen it's always a joy
to come back to maui and there's such
special magic to be here on this
property with you and your family but
i'm very appreciative to be here as well
um but you've been decades a
decades-long vegan for what is it 40
years 40 years 1981. that is amazing and
so inspiring and you're a pioneer in the
plant-based movement and i know so many
people are so thankful for all the
wisdom you have to share so yeah just
thank you again
my honor my pleasure and i gotta tell
you my mom loves you you are her
favorite plant-based doctor
and you know i've been vegan for quite a
long time now nothing that me or my
sister ever did
really i mean she's always been so
supportive and loved making us vegan
food but you know not plant-based
herself it wasn't until last year when
she watched an interview with you that
just clicked within her and she suddenly
was had a spark of passion to be plum
plant-based overnight became plant-based
and now she's so passionate she tells
all her friends anyone who's
experiencing you know symptoms of old
age as they've gotten older she's like
you've got to go plant based check out
dr clapper and yeah i just thank you
amazing well good for her that's great
to hear totally well let's get into it i
wanted to first ask you if you could
share a little bit about your vegan
story
oh my uh well
it was 1980 when i grew up eating
standard western diet my mother didn't
know your mother didn't know who knew
back then and so i ate the standard uh
american fare and i was overweight and
had a few health issues
and was 1981 and i was a resident in
anesthesiology at vancouver general
hospital in vancouver bc i was going to
be an anesthesiologist i thought
and
day after day i'm in the operating room
and
on the cardiovascular service you deal
with people's hearts and blood vessels
so day after day i'm putting people to
sleep and i'm watching surgeons open up
their chest and open up the arteries in
their heart and pull this yellow guck
out of their arteries
and i knew what that stuff was there was
already reports in the medical
literatures largely the fat of the
animals these folks are eating
uh one day a surgeon pulled out a
particularly yellow slithery piece of
atherosclerotic material and i thought
to myself boy that stuff looks like
chicken fat
and little voice on my shoulders there
there's a good reason why it looks like
chicken fat doctor and it is chicken fat
and cow fat and
and it's the remnants of these of these
fatty cholesterol-laden meals that we're
eating
and my dad died of clogged arteries i
know i've got those genes and so i knew
i if i didn't change my diet i was going
to be on that operating table that
striker saw going up my sternum and i
sure didn't want that to happen
so i was getting messages from my left
brain saying adopt a plant-based diet
because there already studies as i said
in the literature showing you can melt
this plaque away with a plant-based diet
so i was getting
intellectually
driven to change my diet but what really
moved me was something that spoke to my
heart a few months into my residency
i'm out dining with a friend another
anesthesia resident
and i had been striving to live a life
of non-violence i had seen so much
violence in the
trauma unit at cook county hospital in
chicago i really wanted to remove the
violence out of my own life at least if
i can free the world of it
and so i studied gandhi and the indian
saints and these folks to
learn how to live a life of non-violence
and i was uh
pontificating about such a lifestyle
to my friend while polishing off a
t-bone steak at the local kagan cleaver
and he was listening with great
compassion so that's all very nice
michael but if you want to really get
the violence out of your life you might
want to start with that piece of meat on
your plate because in
in satisfying your desire for the taste
of flesh in your mouth you are paying
for the death of this beautiful animal
and for the next one in line at the
slaughterhouse
well as soon as he said that all the old
rationalizations sprang into my head
well
that's what they raised them for and the
animals did already and all of that but
before i could get the words out of my
lips then that same little voice on my
shoulder said you know
he's right he's right
and when i went up to pay for the steak
dinner i felt complicit and i cried
because i'd done a lot of my growing up
on my uncle's dairy farm in wisconsin
and i know the reality of putting meat
in the table it's it's a violent act no
matter how you look at it i chopped the
heads off chickens i saw the butcher
come out and shoot the old dairy cows in
the head there's no way to get meat on
the table without causing
dreadful harm and death to these
beautiful animals who love their life as
much as i do
and at that point i i knew my meeting
days were over between what i was seeing
in the or about my own arteries and
knowing the greater truth of living a
life of compassion
uh suddenly the plant-based
style of eating became very uh it was
the only place to go i had no choice
and
so i adopted a vegan diet boy my body
loved it within 12 weeks a 20 pound
spare tire of fat melted off my waist my
high blood pressure went to normal my
cholesterol went to normal i felt great
waking up in a nice lean body every day
and at that point i
realized i didn't want to be an
anesthesiologist anymore and spend my
life putting people to sleep i'd rather
go back to general practice and help
them wake up
and so i did i had much to my parents
dismay as i left that lucrative
profession behind
but i went back to general practice and
found some folks who gave plant-based
cooking lessons in the area and those
folks who could hear the plant-based
message
experienced the same wonderful uh
changes i did they they lost weight
their high blood pressure came down
their diabetes got better
and that was uh 40 plus years ago and
i've been a plant-based physician ever
since and uh
and
there's there's nothing else to do it's
the greatest joy in the world to see
people get healthy and knowing that i'm
that i'm not contributing to the
violence in this world so um
so i got a big v in my heart there and
uh
how to go into a burger restaurant and
order a hamburger and eat it it's just
yeah you know i'd rather flap my arms
and fly to the moon just i just couldn't
do that right and i think it's so
interesting how you talk about how it's
all encompassing and that's it makes it
so much so much more valuable and
interesting when you know it's not just
for your health but also for the animals
and how it's lighter on the footprint
for the planet and i think it's so
interesting what you said about as soon
as it was pointed out that you were you
know encouraging that with the steak on
your plate i think it's so true that
people are all against animal cruelty
everyone is no one no one's for animal
cruelty until it comes to the animals
that they're eating right and then you
have all the rationale and all the
reasons to say why it's okay or why you
need it and since you know through the
scientific literature and your own
experience as a general practitioner
that like you do not need to be eating
animals and actually in fact it'll
enhance your health that's why it's like
such a testament for this movement yeah
we've got there's this protein myth
that's infiltrated into the awareness
you must eat animal flesh every day no
you don't we are
basically
plant-eating hominids we've got the same
basic digestive system that our gorilla
and bonobo cousins have and they're up
in the trees eating leaves and fruits
and they don't develop the diseases we
do
and we got fingers on our hands not
claws we got these long intestines for
digesting fiber we've got enzymes in our
saliva to digest starch you know is that
not a clue about you know about our our
basic nature here and when we start
eating the flesh of the mountain lion um
it damages us and causes disease and so
uh yes no the plants are our fuel and we
should eat them totally it's the win so
we know this you've been vegan for 40
years now i've been vegan 15 years had
four wonderfully healthy vegan
pregnancies all my children are thriving
our whole family vegan
but what do people need to know about
plant food eating how do you dissect and
explain to someone who's new to
understanding it oh well first of all
relax
you know i've never had a gorilla in the
office saying doc i don't get enough
protein you know the the protein are in
the whole plant food where am i gonna
get my protein it's in the grains in the
quinoa and the millet and the buckwheat
it's in the legumes the beans and peas
and chickpeas and lentils
all green vegetables here protein all
plant foods have protein and so relax
about the protein
and
it's easy for people well it's expensive
to eat this way no it's not the staples
of the where you get your calories and
your protein rice and beans and potatoes
are cheap you can buy a 10 pound bag of
lentils for 12 bucks and you can eat all
of that for for a month along with some
rice and potatoes and some starches etc
so relax about the protein it's not
expensive
and it's a delicious way to eat uh
now the once you get the the calories
and the protein covered from the grains
and legumes etc then you've got to get
your vitamins and minerals and those are
in all the live fresh food that's why
that's why you want big salads and
hearty vegetable soups and steamed
greens etc and the more color the better
and if you do that you're basically
covered and uh and it's a delicious
cuisine you can eat it in any ethnic and
and uh international style you want and
mexican chilies and asian stir-fries and
the all these wonderful variations on
the on the flavors
and the only thing you need to do um
you've got to get some vitamin b12 in
and people say aha well see it's a
deficient diet no it's not uh while
you're not eating meat
cows don't make vitamin b12 which you
need for your brain and your spinal cord
you need some
but it does animals don't make it no
animal makes it it's made by microbes in
the soil
and when we were living earth connected
lives uh you know a thousand years ago
or more now every time we pulled a root
out of the ground and ate it there would
be microbes making b12 on the surface
there we would get our b12 the same
place to deer in the antelope get it now
where we would uh
when we were thirsty we'd find a stream
and plop down and drink water from the
stream there'd be b12 in the stream
water when we were connected with the
earth
b12 deficiency wasn't an issue but now
thanks to modern sanitation which i'm
all for yeah
the
natural sources of b12 have dropped out
nobody's drinking out of streams
nobody's eating unwashed vegetables and
so for that reason if you're a pure
plant eater uh then yeah you need
something with b12 in it you know once
or twice a week either a fortified food
a little b12 drop under your tongue or
something but there should in no way
deter anybody from from a food
plant-based diet right and even some
animal farms are injecting b12 into the
animals themselves
these days so you're still supplementing
you're just like passing it through the
animal first yeah really it's second
hand b12 yeah you know the animal didn't
make it yes totally so what do you have
to say to someone who thinks there's
this like rising opinion now that
saturated fat is actually good for you
that we need saturated fat but it's it's
not in the in the volumes that we're
eating yeah you need a little saturated
fat and that's what avocados are for in
olives and then coconuts you know and
you have to have a piece of coconut have
an avocado you get all the saturated fat
that you need but that's not an issue
and we now know that saturated fats in
large amounts are pro-inflammatory they
fan inflammatory reactions throughout
the body and joints and skin
and connective tissue so no you don't
need saturated fat in the amount you
know
if you've got a t-bone steak dripping
with fat oh that's good for my body no
it's not and
it contributes to inflammation in the
artery walls as well and folks who eat a
lot of saturated fat are far more likely
to get
heart attacks and strokes so
but get it out of plants and again
gorillas by and large don't get
atherosclerosis even though they're
eating they might be eating coconuts and
fatty foods totally so one of my
favorite lines and quotes you've ever
had that i've shared multiple times on
my social channels is that the human
body has no more need for cow's milk
than it does for dogs milk horses milk
or draft milk
absolutely somehow we got this idea that
the milk of a cow is somehow beneficial
for us
and
i have a t-shirt outside saying baby
cow's milk is baby calf growth fluid
that's what this stuff is and it's full
of growth factors and and hormones uh
the cows are all pregnant nowadays and
so that's full of estrogens and
progesterone and estradiol and and the
more dairy a boy eats the highest risk
of prostate cancer because estrogens
make the prostate unstable the more the
dairy a young girl eats the higher risk
of precocious puberty and breast cancer
and yet we've got this idea that the
milk of a cow is somehow beneficial
what's in it protein and calcium well
you get protein out of beans get calcium
out of greens we just have no need for
this any more than the the milk of a
giraffe and i said would you pour dog
milk on your cereal would you would you
pour an ice cold glass of rat milk and
drink that down or we'd go yuck well
what's this with these big bovines you
know so
i haven't drunken drunk the milk of a
cow and you know since uh my 20s and i
haven't missed it at all and and
nowadays well there's all these
wonderful plant oat milk and hemp milk
and almond milk and soy milk there's
just absolutely no need to pour the milk
of a cow in your cereal
what was it like growing up on a dairy
farm
well
my um
i spent my first 16 summers my uncle's
dairy farm in wisconsin and
i i really fell in love with cows
they're such sweet animals but there's a
sadness in the dairy barn and i would
always feel that i never knew why
but in order for the cows to keep giving
milk
people think oh cows in the dairy barn
giving milk that's what they do no they
don't there's only one reason those big
bovines are lactating they like all
other mammals they've just had a baby
and in order to keep that milk flowing
you got to keep making those cows
pregnant they carry the calf for nine
months
just like a human mother does
they have their 65 pound baby
with much labor
and then they're lactating to feed the
child but my uncle that calf is the
enemy he's taken that calf is drinking
up his profits he wants that milk for
himself to sell to the dairy
and so within 24 hours 48 sometimes my
uncle would come and scoop that calf up
and put him in the veal pen
down at the end of the barn
and that mother cow would bellow
hour after hour after hour the most
heart-rending soul-tearing cries her
baby is you know 10 yards away in this
veal pen and she can't get to it and i
would hear it it would haunt me i was an
eight-year-old kid and my summer's
laying i could hear these cows bellow
from my bed
and i didn't understand what was going
on but now i understand what's going on
there's such inherent cruelty
in dairy production you you must be
taking those calves away from the babies
and
from their mothers
and so with all their innocence and and
intentional ignorance on the part of the
dairy marketers
every woman who's in the supermarket and
reaches for that greek yogurt and then
that cheese
she's and pays for it she's saying take
another calf away from its mother you
know then let's make another mother
suffer
and these cows would be in the stanchion
these big tears going down their their
cheeks and uh pictures of it and i
couldn't understand what
where the sadness was but now i know and
uh
so that was you know one of the most
lasting impressions and that i had there
i had wonderful times on the farm i was
driving tractors when i was eight years
old and plowing fields and uh
sling hay bales up on the far up on the
hayloft and it was a wonderful place to
be
but the reality of milk and and meat
production um we we had pigs that were
shot and cows old dairy cows would get
shot
and uh and well just the way it is
michael my uncle would say and uh but
now i know it doesn't have to be that
way that whole thing you know we used to
harpoon whales you know and now we go oh
my god what were we thinking well it
should be the same thing with with the
dairy product oh we used to raise these
big bovines and then we cut their
throats and and eat their flesh and
hopefully it'll be in those who i can't
believe we used to do that category i
hope so too i mean obviously i i really
feel like dairy and cow's milk is the
most obvious non-human feud
just from a mother perspective and i
think a lot of women have made that
connection through understanding that i
didn't know growing up i thought cows
just make milk just to make milk but
they make milk for their babies and just
the thought of having your baby torn
away after giving birth it's just the
most horrendous thing and there's really
no other way to go about it i think
people have this false sense this idea
that if it's raw dairy or organic and
pasteurized that means they're somehow
nicer to the cows and the cows get to
hang out and drink as much milk as they
want
so all those cows are destined to have
their heads cut off and
and the baby calves if you're a male
unfortunate enough to be a boy calf
you're going to spend four months and
that will reveal chained by your neck
until your and your flesh gets all soft
and white because you're not exercising
and uh
and then the veal farmer comes and i'll
take that one and they cut its throat
and sell it for milk fed veal but and
people don't think that the veal
industry those calves getting
killed
is an is an essential offset offshoot of
the dairy industry to keep that milk
flowing you're going to keep killing
those calves and then people should know
they're paying for that and there's no
need for that
and as anymore and there never was but
certainly nowadays there's just no need
for it it's a should it's an antique
that should recede into history's
dustbin totally what do you think about
people who think raw milk is healthier
for you and it's actually good for you
if it's raw just not pasteurized well
they're kidding themselves on a number
of levels that um i'm not saying you
know you're talking about a a material
at the beginning that doesn't really
have good nutritional value for us
there's nothing in cow's milk that we
need as i said protein calcium now you
get that out of plants
but the
uh
why do they pasteurize
milk in the first place because cows get
tuberculosis and the the pasteurization
was first applied to milk to stop
because it stopped bovine tb because
people would drink the milk and back in
the 1920s tuberculosis of the stomach
was a common cause of death and was
coming from the milk
and so um so that's where pasteurization
really came from and no it's not gentle
with the milk you raise it up to 150
degrees and i'm sure you're going to
denature some proteins etc
but
and so that makes it even a little less
desirable but the substance itself again
it's meant to fuel a baby calf and there
and
the more dairy a woman consumes the more
estrogen she consumes the more breast
lump she gets they get fibroids from big
uterus they get more bleeding they get
hysterectomies they're why they would
make a stand to uh that i want my
definitely this is good for me no it's
not you're not a baby calf i say go look
in the mirror you got big ears you got
snout with whiskers if you're a baby
calf cool but if you're not
have oat milk can we have rice milk on
your cereal right because pasteurizing
it doesn't take all that other stuff no
the hormones are still there the white
blood cells are still there the the
bacteria still you know most of them are
still there
uh and the hormones are still there no
there's nothing magical about raw milk
and it's a little bit more dangerous
because uh there's more bacteria in it
right so so i think there's like a
divide and a lot of people like we all
know both sides of the spectrum whether
you're pro-eating animal products or
pro-plant-based that processed foods
aren't healthy for us they're not good
for us but i think this other side of
the spectrum is saying well it's the
processed foods that are the problem
don't blame the animal foods what's
really the pros it's the processed foods
so what do you have to say to someone
who's like all about the grass-fed and
free range and all that and saying that
that's actually good for us yeah well
two things first of all they're kidding
themselves on a number of levels
um i i totally agree with them the more
we process food the deader and more
pathogenic it gets and the frying and
the and the chemicals and all this stuff
evil we agree food should be eaten whole
as nature created them i agree
but
and when people change their diets from
a from a
from a processed food diet with burger
buns and cheetos and all that stuff to
even if they're eating meat and veggies
in a clean way there they're gonna feel
better they're gonna losing weight their
bowels will work better and
absolutely enough say yeah that's what i
ought to eat
but as the physician who treats chronic
disease
as people are eating
meat meals and animal muscle meal after
meal i had to say what kind of microbes
are you spawning in your gut
what do you
follow these people along how much
colitis do they get how much crohn's
disease do they get what are they doing
to their artery walls and you know they
feel great for the first six months ten
years from now
you know the doctor's recommending these
and you gotta
be around when um when this guy in ten
years passes his first bloody stool from
the colon cancer that your high meat
diet spawn and has got well you will be
around you're off to your new luxury spa
appointment in phoenix there you won't
even see it there's drive-by medical
advice they have no idea what they're
really saying in the long-term effects
it'll be around when 15 years this lady
has her stroke from that big old carotid
artery plaque that's your meat-based
diet spawn we'll be around to see that
but that but that's what happens here we
are plant-eating hominids and a
flesh-based diet violates natural law to
the extent that we get these diseases
and a high fat diet makes you insulin
resistant and so they wind up with
diabetes and all the bad luck no it's
not so
you're clogging up your insulin
receptors with all the saturated fat
so all the way around these these folks
like dr mcdougall says people love to
hear good news about bad habits you know
anything that lets them rationalize oh i
want to keep eating that meat because
they like the taste the steak in their
mouth that's really what it comes down
to but if you're talking health you're
talking about long-term longevity you're
talking about getting to your 70s i just
turned 74.
i'm taking no medications i've
go for 30-mile bike rides i just feel
great if you want to get to your
advanced years without being a medical
patient or god forbid having a stroke or
a heart attack
then then stop kidding yourself and
that the the food you're eating through
the decades before that doesn't make a
big difference your your body's never
not looking you know there's no kid in
your your arteries you know your liver
knows what you ate your kidneys know
what you ate and uh but these folks are
kidding themselves because they want to
keep the you know stay in the club of
the paleo folks and
and i'll see them in the clinic i'll see
them in the operating room unfortunately
and that that's my fear about this and
this short-term pleasure for long-term
problems right so america is riddled
with chronic diseases and illness from
diet and lifestyle factors mostly why is
there so much confusion especially and
even amongst the medical community and
why is it that you know someone could
say well look at this scientific paper
it shows this and then they'll say well
look at this one what is it how do you
how do you weigh both sides like i've
heard that it was like for every one um
scientific paper showing that
plant-based eating is healthy or that
meat eating is healthy then there's five
showing that plant-based is healthy like
how do you how do you sift through it
especially as a layman it's gotten so
much like politics these days you know
the same thing and in fact politics has
found its way into into the science here
and money has corrupted it as well the
when the yeah the
nutritional guidelines for americans are
made up by the the department of
agriculture okay
why is the agriculture department making
up the dietary guidelines um now lately
the um the food folks the food nutrition
folks have gotten in but they must run
all their recommendations through the
through the agriculture department where
the meat and dairy guys sit around the
table oh no you can't say that no can't
say that you got to have me milked with
every meal you got to have meat with
every meal and so you know so that's
influenced the message we're getting
from government and from their
scientists um and money talks uh
some famous quote that it's difficult to
uh to convince a man of one viewpoint
when he's getting paid to have the
opposite viewpoint yes and uh so you get
that conflict
and then you and the studies are are
done you can skew a study easily have
too few uh subjects uh just pick out
certain things that got better while
ignoring things that got worse there's
there's ways to skew the presentation to
say aha see it's it's a better diet
but clearly these diseases were
retreating that clog up the uh the
emergency rooms the operating rooms etc
there are artery disease or diseases of
obesity there's diseases of arteries
diseases of hormones and
you didn't used to see these when we
were eating largely plant-based diets
and i'm not saying we've always been
vegans but we see they usually meet once
a week twice we couldn't afford more
than that meat used to be expensive
before the government started
subsidizing the meat production
and a two dollar burger is is an
outrageous deception uh if those
if the meat producers really had to pay
for the true cost of putting that burger
on the table if they had to pay
for the soil erosion for the water that
they pollute for the water that they use
for the trees that were cut down that
that should be growing in and absorbing
carbon dioxide if they had to pay for
all of that then these burgers would
cost 80 bucks apiece and then people
would eat them once a year as
it should
and so
so money and politics
and uh ulterior
ulterior motives have skewed a lot of
what we call what we recognize as
science these days and uh you're right
and and the dueling study
the
conflicts are very unsatisfying and i
really try and stay away away from that
because it doesn't generates a lot more
heat than light right because going to
common sense like you take the science
but also common sense and logic plays a
huge role in like how i decide what i
believe because you really need both you
can't just look at the scientific papers
you gotta look at the fact that cow's
milk is for baby cows stuff like that
and just the factors of like the
politics like you say the food subsidies
completely distorts reality on what
foods should cost the fact that ahead of
broccoli costs more than a cheeseburger
makes absolutely no sense at all there's
no big broccoli lobbying like there is
animal agriculture lobbying and i think
a lot of people just have no clue most a
lot of people don't even know that food
subsidies exist and that most of them
are going towards animal foods or the
grain and the corn to feed the animals
absolutely and like some of it towards
processed foods but largely for the
animal food so
you're right if there was like an if we
had a real understanding of how much
these foods should cost and what if they
cost the way that they should people
would be eating far less animal foods
and they have such
a power within our government and it's
unfortunate really but like knowing
knowing all this and how it all ties in
together for the planet for how food
subsidies have affected our economies
and the pollution that happens within
animal agriculture from animal poop
runoff from our ocean depletion
all of that together what do people need
to know about how it ties in together
with our planet oh my this is the most
powerful
argument
that can exist
that people need to be aware of and i
would urge your
viewers to get a little book by glenn
mercer called food is climate
and in these few pages he makes it very
clear that we are headed for
environmental disaster
uh as we all know the planet's getting
warmer the ice caps are melting the
storms are getting worse etc
why is this heavy well there's all this
carbon dioxide in the air and it's
coming from the auto exhaust let's get
on electric cars and that'll solve the
problem
no it won't and he makes it very clear
and to al gore and elon musk and all
these folks promoting these
technological fixes
they're they're going to make this much
difference
the only thing if we're talking about
taking carbon dioxide out of the air and
reversing climate change there's only
one way to do it on any practical level
and it has nothing to do with big
machines just suck carbon dioxide out of
the air and pump it into the ground
nature is way ahead of us she came up
with the best carbon capture device of
all time they're called trees
and we should seriously consider this
and i'm not about boy scouts out there
planting trees though let's talk some
some real numbers here
on planet earth before humans started
cutting them down there are there were
about 6 trillion trees on planet earth
well in the last in a blink of a
geological eye in 200 years 500 years
we've cut down over half of them we've
cut down 3 trillion there's less than 3
trillion trees left and when you cut
down a tree and burn it
you not only
release its carbon dioxide into the air
you've taken away this wonderful carbon
dioxide trap because as trees grow they
take carbon dioxide the air and turn it
into solid wood
and
and
all we need to do is
mother nature you don't even have to
plant the forest she will like if we
stop cutting them down the trees will
come back and that's all we need to do
hmm where are we going to plant three
trillion trees on the land that they
used to grow on that you cleared to grow
make pasture land to graze cattle
and to make these vast corn and soybean
fields to feed the cows and pigs and
that you eat if we would stop eating
animals
not only would we be healthier but they
would free up the land for the forest to
come back and as the trees grow they
take the carbon dioxide of the air and
climate change would reverse
and there is no other solution
it's the one that's the cheapest and
easiest everybody
could choose the bean chili instead of
the beef chili you know that's all we're
saying you know it's there's no great
sacrifice here but just if this to stop
raising we you know we kill 80 billion
animals on planet earth every year 80
billion cows pigs chickens
we kill them all if we stop doing that
and
nourish ourselves on plants that will
free up this land and and only a half of
it that used to grow trees needs to
have the forest come back that would
take enough carbon dioxide out of the
air to stop global warming
that's the only thing that's going to
work at this time and until we come to
that that the the lights are flashing
humans as individuals you want to stay
healthy you want to avoid heart attacks
and strokes stop eating animals homo
sapiens as a species you want to keep
living on this planet with a livable
climate stop eating animals the the
lights are just flashing as brightly as
they could be
and there's no argument and the paleo
folk being meat three times a day out
what planet are you on literally what
planet are you on not this one that's
dying from our carnivory our it's our
our lust free animal flesh that's
growing and growing by the year that's
going to to
to cause our demise and the collapse of
our society and
and and and the vegans have been saying
this for a year john robin's been saying
this and dying from new america and
francis more lepay and all these folks
for since i got into the movement in the
80s and long before that
but i
said uh please read glenn mercer's book
on
on
fuji's climate there's another little
book by dr richard oppenlander called
comfortably unaware which is right where
the meat and dairy industries want us
okay read those two books
and see if the a hamburger looks the
same to you because that's your
children's future i see your four
beautiful children they're they're just
a delight to be around but i i think my
god when they're my age what what is
this planet going to look like and what
are we doing to them what right do we
have to steal their future for for cheap
cheeseburgers and t-bone steaks
it's time for us to realize and with the
internet and global awareness now we the
whole planet can come to this
the age of meat eating is over we we've
used it up whatever
function the mighty hunter
and all that mythology that that area is
done like whaling it's done
fishing you know with these massive 10
mile long nets to scoop everything out
of the ocean we've used fishing up it's
time to let the oceans heal it's time to
let the forest heal it's time to make
peace with the natural world if we do
will be
granted a garden of eden to live in
but the but the price of the mission to
that stable world is a plant-based diet
and and again what is it if you have you
have
pasta primavera instead of pasta with
meatballs you know
uh have it with vegetables instead of
instead of the meat that's the great
sacrifice
you know our name as a species homo
sapiens the word sapient isn't english
from the latin sapien means wise wisdom
okay homo sapien the wise one you know
the one thing we're lacking is the
wisdom to know that this costs too much
of flesh-based diet and and it's time
for that to end and now with all these
impossible burgers and all stuff i'm not
saying they're bastions of healthy food
but it if they're if it takes that they
want well then eat that as a transition
food there comes a point you leave those
behind too
but if if that's what you're looking for
that meaty texture to bite into then you
they can even have that from plants now
so please if you care about this planet
if you care about animals if you care
about children if you care about your
future
i've got little good nephews and nieces
and and i fear for them like i fear for
your children
um it's time for us to grow up as a
species to someone you know grab us up
and say listen times be to honor your
anatomy and adopt a plant-based diet and
if we do that everything will get better
the
the soils will stabilize the rivers will
start running clear again the the
climate will
will stabilize the the forest will come
back and we'll be healthier we won't
have tie up our hospitals with with
the coronary artery bypasses et cetera
and there'll be money not spent on
health care yes to fix the roads put
internet in everybody's house make
college free we could do so much else
just pay for the disease that we're
creating with the flesh-based diet the
wisdom are you kidding
you know it's the most unwise thing to
do so
and i know all vegans they're all
hippies
please listen to the message listen to
the science listen to the biology listen
to your heart
would you eat raw flesh would you ever
eat a raw steak no you got a cookie out
of disguise it doesn't that tell you
does your mouth salivate when you see a
dead carcass on the ground is it
no we're plant-eating creatures if we
just honor that everything will start to
heal and until we do we're going to have
an increasingly worse problem so
this is a matter of life and future yeah
i mean you touched on so many things i
fully agree with you about the you know
we don't want to see a dead carcass we
don't want to see animals skinned
and dismembered there's nothing
appetizing about it that's that's the
reason why it's not shown on social
media people don't want to see that like
it's just yes meat's good for you but
like i'm just going to disguise it and
i'm not going to show you the process of
it because it's not no one likes to see
that and we're not going to take
children to a trip to the slaughterhouse
we take them strawberry picking and we
find
picking plant foods to be so much more
beautiful and i've said this multiple
times before i totally agree with you
and when it comes to it's interesting
how powerful the food subsidies really
make a difference because if we're going
to subsidize anything we should be
subsidizing the plant foods that are
good for us that helps our health care
costs it's good for our health and it's
better for the earth you know i think a
lot of people don't realize that pla
eating plants requires so much less land
than if you're eating animal foods even
and especially actually if you're eating
pasteurized animal foods like
pasteurized cows they require so much
more
so much more land it's completely not
sustainable and especially encouraging
people to eat even more of it doesn't
make any sense at all and
something even as specific as like
animal poop there's just no one thinks
about where does that poop go and
because the cows are such large animals
and they're feeding them with so much
corn and grain that they they have a lot
of poop and it's gotta go somewhere it
goes they they take so much more poop up
than the humans even we don't even think
about that like all that about where
it's going running off into our rivers
and lakes and um oh yeah there's just so
so many factors sure and this whole
regenerative agriculture myth that you
know again it's another
hoax to make us feel better about eating
meat but the reality is you know the the
underlying
concept is a good one to regenerate the
soils we've not been gentle with the
soils and we've just been pumping
chemicals into them and sucking
feed crops and you know feed corn and
soybeans out of them and the soils are
getting depleted and of their vitality
absolutely we need to regenerate them
and so i'm all for cover crops and crop
rotations and no-till agriculture no
pesticides herbicides yay i'm all for
that but then they say oh and then we
need to graze the animals but we keep
need to move them around um so so they
don't over graze any area um
well wait a minute first of all you know
the illusion of grass-fed beef there um
they're worse for the environment than
the feedlot beef well how can that be
because they live a year or two longer
and and every day those cows are
belching out methane they're breathing
out carbon dioxide they're putting
manure on the ground that
releases methane
as it degenerates and they do it for two
more years than the feed block the beef
do that gets their fruit cut at 16
months these these animals will live for
two to three years
and they require so much more land if
they're just grazing
that
you're going to be creating
you're using up more land to create more
carbon dioxide and methane for what uh
you put a piece of steak on the table
this one's
grown regeneratively and this one's
feedlot can you tell the difference
going to guarantee me that that that the
cow that was from um used to be on the
regenerative farm has been actually
rotated around the paddocks you know can
i tell that in the supermarket looking
there okay stop kidding yourself this is
all an illusion now to keep doing what
we're doing
and i keep remembering this this movie
and probably your
your viewers might be a little young but
there's a movie called thelma and louise
susan sarandon and somebody else and
these two
adult women friends get on the wrong
side of the law and they wind up killing
a guy or whatever and they're fugitives
and uh and they don't there's nothing
else to do and the police are closing in
on them and so they look at each other
they're by the grand canyon and
they hold hands and then louise hits the
gas and they just pitch out into the
grand canyon uh and you know that's
where the movie ends there and then the
convertible as they're you know going
into the grand canyon and it seems
that's what we're doing now
the governments could be doing so much
more stop the animal subsidy start
putting ads on tv eat plants you know if
you really wanted to change society we
could do it but we're just playing
thelma louise and we're going over the
cliff and uh
and how dare we do that to your children
and and all the kids and and this
beautiful planet
so um so these folks um who are you know
playing the
regenerative agriculture game and the
grass-fed game and also if they're all
kidding themselves they're they're
eating death and it's going to be their
own unfortunately in the death of the
planet right i think there's a lot it's
um they try people try really hard to
make it seem like it is normal and
natural and because if you do grow up on
like you said you grew up on a dairy
farm it did feel normal somewhat like it
was hard to understand as a child we
listen to our parents we you know
understand the world and the best we
know how based on growing up or if we're
raised to you know think that hunting is
fine and oh well i'm actually not
disgusted by an animal being dismembered
that's that's really comes from just
conditioning and being used to seeing
something over and over again which
happens in all different kinds of
experiences in people's lives but that
doesn't if you really get down to the
heart of it we know that we want we we
teach children to be kind animals and in
fact if a child isn't is showing
tendencies to not be kind to animals we
kind of consider that a concern because
we want you to be kind oh don't be
gentle be gentle to the cat don't don't
hurt the kitty's tail you know but but
here have some have some eggs have some
have some raw milk and meat and all that
stuff i think it's just there's a
disconnect and it's easy because we're
so disconnected from the way the world
absolutely used to be for sure
absolutely um so what about the farmers
what do they do if more and more people
start eating plants and there's like
this natural
demand and shift towards plant foods
what do the animal farmers do oh thank
you for that that's so important and uh
and it's easy if you're a dairy farmer
or a bee farmer to get your back up when
you're here they're going to throw me
off my land you're going to take away my
livelihood no
uh not at all sir or madam um
these folks are not the enemy they're
our brothers and sisters and they're
growing our food for us to help these
people um then
all you have to see is you don't have to
run cattle let's do something else with
the land grow fruit trees grow broccoli
grow industrial hemp if it if the land
well my land's all rocky essential if it
can grow grass enough to to for cattle
to graze on that it can grow industrial
hemp it can grow a whole lot of crops um
and and pay these folks make it easy for
them take a
build of a couple less aircraft carriers
or close a couple military bases and
take those billions of dollars
and set up the agricultural fairness
administration and help these people
send them to night school to learn how
to grow new crops buy their seeds formed
by their equipment form you know give
them crop insurance pay the mortgage on
their house for 10 years give their kids
scholarships to college make it easier
for them to make the transition don't
grind them up in the gears of economics
here help them they're growing our food
and just say yeah my daddy grew cattle
now for since 1892 on this one well
there's you know we used to harpoon
whales too but that doesn't mean you
still have to do that let's
we're bright creatures here do something
else with that land and pay them to to
watch the forest pay them to be good
foresters and promote the the clean up
the streams and
and nourish the land there's so much
else we could do these these folks are
not the enemy they're there to be helped
and we could do it whatever the money
and political will is all that it takes
and so we need to
need to retool re-revision uh the entire
issue of food production and and change
it to swerve it over to the plant-based
side and and bring these people along
that even goes for yeah like even the
farmers growing corn and soy for the
animal right good for people grow people
crops yeah absolutely because a lot of
people think that the soy oh soy see
soy's mad but most of it's going towards
it's going down to gullets of cows and
pigs and chickens very little of it
winds up in tofu and soy burgers outside
they're growing animal fat or they're
growing cheeseburgers right so let's
shift a little bit i want to talk about
your moving medicine forward initiative
and what you've been doing now it's very
exciting and there's i feel like it's
such a bright it's a shows me a bright
future what you're doing right now with
you know your next chapter educating
doctors for the next generations can you
just tell us about it absolutely well as
a physician
who spent my first 30 years in practice
treating diabetes and high blood
pressure and clogged arteries and
obesity etc you know the the penny
dropped that this is what from what
they're eating of course uh and and i
look at my colleagues in the very
especially the cardiologists they're
focused on well he needs statins he
needs stents and uh
but all this is coming from what we're
eating by 90 of this and and i'm
embarrassed as a physician i'm
embarrassed for my my profession that
we can you know our science is so
powerful we can
pick out a genetic mismatch on gene 821
on chromosome 14 boy we can hone in on
that with precision
but the thought that is that our
patients eating cheeseburgers and
pepperoni pizzas might be clogging up
their arteries this is somehow too
abstruse a concept we haven't do we have
proof of this so it's tell me 20
double-blind placebo-controlled studies
that show me that eating broccoli is
healthier than cheeseburgers ah you
don't have those studies to see them go
go away till you do you do
and people love and there's an inertia
the and and that keeps this ignorance
going and it's ignorance uh and
and the young docs
at this point somebody
when i when i get up to lecture them i
say i'm going to give you the lecture i
wish somebody had given me 50 years ago
when i was a first year med student it
would have changed every diagnosis i
made would have changed every treatment
plan i made it's the food your patients
are eating before you order another
thousand dollar scan another 500 set of
lab tests stop ask what they ate
yesterday to have them take you through
an eating day and if it's full of
burgers and buffalo wings and pepperoni
peaches that's why they're sitting in
front of you doctor
overweight diabetic hypertensive clogged
up and inflamed from what they're
running through their bloodstream every
four hours and if you change that
it's study get them on a plant-based
send the patient to the plant-based
dietitian let her do the counseling let
her show in the movies let her take him
shopping you see him back in a month and
if they've gone plant-based you'll see
they're leaner and their blood pressures
down and they are healthier folks this
is how medicine should be practiced in
the 21st century
and in my slide presentation i put a
pretty provocative slide up saying
knowing that how reversible because
these diseases are reversible it's this
most exciting thing in medicine to see
the obesity melt away and the and the
arteries relax and high blood pressure
go down the joints stop hurting and the
psoriatic skin clears up and the
asthmatic lungs stop wheezing and the
migraine headaches get better and they
turn into normal healthy people right in
front of your eyes that don't need a
bunch of pills and potions and
procedures
i say this slide says you want to heal
these people or don't you
i mean really why are you going
tremendous you want to heal them or are
you just going to be their seam every
month to raise their dose of metformins
and and beta blockers and say come back
in two months if that's how you're going
to practice medicine you're going to
leave your medicine you won't you'll
burn out this is the most dismal kind of
medicine hopeless medicine because
you're telling your patients you'll
you'll never get well you're always
going to be diabetic you're always going
to have hypertension you'll know you're
you're always going to be sick
what a hopeless message you want to heal
these people and get real about what
they're eating
and so i show them a slideshow and show
them how a plant-based diet reverses
diabetes however it cleans out arteries
how it settles down inflamed colons how
it clears up psoriasis etc
and there's more than just going
plant-based but it's square one you want
to heal these people and get them on a
plant-based diet
and
as i said i wish someone had told me
that so i've been going around to the
nation's medical schools uh through
north america and canada mexico and
australia new zealand i'm going to be
late in december i'm lecturing over at
burns medical school in honolulu
and giving this message
and it's getting easier because
it is the 21st century and when i step
up to the microphone
and i've got a bunch of med students
there i know that in every medical
school class every first second third
year med school class there's 20 or 30
students they've seen movies like forks
over knives they've seen cowspiracy
they've seen what the hell the light's
on and most of they're ahead of me here
a little bit and it's wonderful and
they're very receptive to the message
and they say i wish my professors were
telling me this
so our moving medicine forward
initiative is to get me in front of as
many medical school audiences as
possible to to turn on as many lights in
these heads because you know they say
once you look behind the curtain you
can't pretend you don't know what's
behind the curtain you know and i'm
trying to rip the curtain down it's the
food it's what your patients are eating
start there the students want to hear
this they know that they are sincerely
want to get their patients healthier and
many of them again are not only opens
the plant-based message many of them are
vegan now themselves they're getting
more and more of those
and if any of your listeners would like
to see what it is i'm actually telling
students go to my website drclapper.com
and and click on moving medicine forward
and see my video called what i wish i
learned in medical school about
nutrition and that's what i tell the
students and
and at the end i say now now you know
what i wish i learned in medical school
about nutrition and now you know it as
well and the students are getting more
and more excited i'm getting more and
more invitations i'm doing more of it
electronically now i
gave this talk at the university of
buffalo last week
at yale i gave it at uh universities
california san diego two weeks ago uh
and i'm able to do uh drop into these
various uh medical audiences from from
afar
and it was discouraging uh not to be
able due to covid to actually be in
front of these students because that's
such a you get such great energy right
from the live audience
but uh it's kind of a silver lining from
the covid virus that i'm able to reach
so many more students now and
visit so many more medical schools from
my own living room
by uh the
magic of electronic media
so uh this is moving medicine forward we
could sure use some help does it cost
money yeah how do we support it to pay
staff etc and if people would like to
make a tax deductible donation again go
to drclapper.com click on moving
medicine forward and you'll see how you
can make a donation there we'd be very
appreciative for any help perfect that's
really helpful to share that information
and i'll definitely be putting the link
to his website below for you to check
out so you can look into that so okay
why is it that medical schools don't
teach this stuff but don't why do they
not learn anything little to nothing
about nutrition it's it's embarrassing
and and again yeah i could be a little
cynical in the fine hand of the
pharmaceutical industry they don't
really don't want to see people getting
really really healthy they you know
they're going to sell a lot less drugs
and they have a big influence about the
curriculum
and um and i gave a talk that the
the at the university of washington
seattle and a surgeon came down
afterwards said you know good talk doc
glad to hear this but you know until
they start asking about nutrition on the
national board exams we're not going to
be teaching this and he's right and so
we went to the national board of medical
examiners and say what will it take for
you folks to uh
to ask about nutrition on the boards and
he said well we don't know anything
about it so uh so i said you bring us
the questions so the i went to a member
of the american college of lifestyle
medicine and there's a committee now
making up a thousand questions on diet
and lifestyle to bring to the uh
national board folks and they're going
to start putting them on the exams and
that's going to start turning the wheel
there
and uh and again the doctors are you
know they've got this image that if
those smart scientists in the lab come
up with a mesocillin you know they're
it's just a matter of time before we can
come up with a magic pill and restore
health and they're kidding themselves
it's lazy medicine you gotta get down to
the cause of disease and that's what
whatever how we're eating and how we're
living our lives
so um it's you know
you can tell the pioneer from all the
arrows in the back there you know and uh
and so i'm we're still in that stage but
there's nothing else for me to do at
this stage in my career except help the
young medical students awaken so i want
to create a a new generation of
nutritionally aware
doctors and dentists and pharmacists and
podiatrists and nurses and physical
therapists and occupations through all
the health professions
once a month we have our plant-based
clinical nutrition forum and people are
welcome to join every month i have a new
uh guest on from the from the healing
professions we talk about how
plant-based nutrition plays a role in
whatever healing discipline they are in
and so it's an exciting time
to see these
powerful modalities plant-based
nutrition that be incorporated into
people's actual lives and their medical
practices so we want to help that happen
as much as possible and
you know the hundredth monkey phenomenon
that you know when the hundredth monkey
learns
a new behavior all the monkeys learn you
know start acting in that way
and so i think we're about monkey number
82 or so uh yeah yeah so we're getting
there but i still got a bunch more
monkeys to convert yet making progress
for sure you're doing so much it's
amazing how much in your last decades
that all that you've done and now this
which seems so impactful it's really
going to make a change as opposed to
just like one-on-one talking to a doctor
here and there being a good example
you're actually speaking to doctors and
how do they continue to learn after your
lecture absolutely uh the last third of
my slide show is filled with all the
resources that are available for to them
and i said go to these websites go to
pcrm physician committee for responsible
medicine the university of winchester in
the uk has a six-week course on
plant-based nutrition take that course
online
they're the american college of
lifestyle medicine has a rich
library of continuing medical education
courses it's free for the taking there's
so much
and
now
there's an organization called the
plantricion project which encourages
plant-based nutrition
based physicians
to
collaborate and they have until kovid
came along our annual meeting we were 2
000 doctors from around the world from
england and ireland and india and
malaysia and argentina they would come
and they're all the plant-based light is
on and all these doctors heads and
hearts and to to see them excitedly talk
about this it fans this wonderful flame
that's starting to get brighter and
brighter
so you're i tell the doctors you're not
alone this is not
california stuff this is solid science
and there's a lot of clinicians there's
plant-based cardiologists or plant-based
pathologists plant-based radiologists
name it the you know it's the lights
going on and all these physicians heads
so uh come and join the party and get on
board because it's gonna take you to
good places you'll see your patients get
healthy and that's why you went into the
healing professions to begin with isn't
a doctor isn't it isn't it a nurse and
so it's an exciting time but there's a
lot of a lot of darkness to push away
but you know it's better to light a
candle than curse the darkness
that's amazing because i do think a lot
of people have poor experiences with
doctors it could be just a pill for
every ill and not really getting to the
root cause how can i change things but i
do have hope that it will change as much
as it's hard because there is so much
corruption within our you know what
they're from what they're taught in
medical school to the food subsidies and
to all the government corruption that
there is unfortunately i do see hope
with with the type of things that you're
doing to help change it and maybe in the
future just maybe we'll be prescribing
more like diet and lifestyle factors
than we will as many
pills
in my lecture i say you at least owe
your patient a four-page handout yeah
you want to reverse your diabetes you
want to reverse your high blood pressure
here go to these websites see this video
read this article and then call ms smith
the plant-based dietitian go see her and
then you come back and see me and uh and
and by the way what did you eat
yesterday you know what how beautiful
they have a physician say those words to
you at your at your visit so that's
we're trying to create a generation of
doctors who have that awareness and
we're getting there because it puts the
control back into you you don't feel so
helpless
you know oh i can actually help this i'm
not just going to manage my type 2
diabetes the rest of my life i could
potentially reverse this yeah absolutely
that's powerful information for sure
yeah absolutely so lastly let's talk
about this other thing that you're doing
which is also amazing which is your
plant-based telehealth can you explain
what that is absolutely uh well i'm
still a practicing physician and i love
working with patients
but due to covid and also just the
reality of
western medicine these days we've gone
online and so now i do telemedicine
exclusively and our organization is
called plantbasetelehealth.com
and if people would like to have a
consultation with me personally i'd love
to hear from you and so go to
plantbasetelehealth.com i'm sure you'll
see it down below here
and you can we've got
nine physicians they're all plant-based
and they're all excellent clinicians and
if you can't get an appointment with me
take one of our other physicians
depending what state you live in
and uh and it's one of the most exciting
fulfilling kinds of medicine i never
thought i would enjoy electronic
medicine but you can tell a lot from
just looking at the patient and hearing
them listening and asking asking
questions and and we can prescribe lab
tests and prescribe medications and you
know we practice medicine yeah yeah but
it's plant-based telehealth.com and and
i would love to hear from your viewers
and and take them honest patience yeah
because that that is super
super cool not only but also empowering
because i think a lot of people they
might feel really alone they're learning
about all this information like oh that
doctor he's so far away how will i get
this information how can i get
one-on-one help but now with the
telehealth that's
makes it possible yeah absolutely so
special okay so i have one more question
for you my mom wanted me to ask you okay
she said so she first of all she's
listened to all your interviews she sees
your passion she just so loves to hear
from you and loves everything you have
to say and she wants to know what keeps
you going and motivated and like not
giving up out of frustration oh my
um
my love for life and love for the
natural world and
to um the the buddhists have a concept
of the bodhisattva the bodhisattva what
does he do he you relieve suffering
wherever you find it
and as a physician that's my calling i
relieve suffering wherever i find it and
just in my heart and spirit whether it's
an injured animal or a crying child
whatever it is that that that impulse to
make you want to scoop them up and take
care of them and comfort them that's
what i want to do the whole planet and
to everybody i see into the animals it's
that
that desire to uh to protect and to heal
on
big levels and small levels um it's in
my heart and every morning it's there
and brighter and stronger so that's what
gets me out of bed and
puts me back to sleep at night with a
smile on my face that's so beautiful i
mean it it really has that to me that
screams purpose you know which is part
of the blue zones one of the nine
nine lifestyle factors that's the
purpose and i i can 100 agree with you
on that it really is super fulfilling
following your passions and your purpose
and hopefully leaving this place better
than it was when you got here yeah
absolutely owe it to your children
for the kids and the animals i mean it's
partly to you from all that i've learned
from doctors like you so that i have
such healthy vibrant children so thank
you beautiful you are so welcome thank
you this made me so happy
thank you so much for this conversation
i could not be more elated and so
thankful whoever's listening got to hear
you speak and share all of your
knowledge so i guess we'll end it we'll
figure out this is amazing or we'll
continue on yeah yeah
making a healthier world that's right
thank you dr klaber thank you
[Music]
you